cheers echoed through the crowd of
onlookers in Davenport Monday after a
missing woman poked her head out of a
fourth floor window about 24 hours after
her building partially collapsed they're
getting her family say this is Lisa
Brooks firefighters rescued her on
Monday evening hours before the
building's demolition was scheduled for
Tuesday morning a family member said
Brooks hid under the couch when the
building gave way and a reported natural
gas leak may have caused her to pass out
the freaking building just collapsed
when First Responders arrived at the
scene Sunday they discovered the back of
the wall of the six-story building torn
away exposing personal belongings inside